[Music]
it's that time of the month again the
playstation plus games are here for
march 2022 and there's five of them so
we don't have time for this introduction
let's do this starting with the ps5 on
the ps5 we get our hands on gta online
to coincide with the release of the
enhanced version of gta 5. this isn't
the single player portion sadly it's
only the online aspect if you haven't
dropped into gta online before a new
career builder option is here for you
instead of slowly making a few dollars
on the street you'll have the funds to
buy one of many businesses on offer and
not be left behind by people who've been
playing for eight years plus there's
been 39 content updates over the years
so even if you have played but dropped
off there's something new for everyone
even dr dre is somehow in the game now
all the visuals have been updated with
4k 60 frames per second support and
tweaks to the aging control system which
should bring it in line with more modern
games oh and those loading times they
are so much more improved we get this on
the day it releases which is march 15th
then we have ghost runner a hugely
underrated free-running melee game which
is sublime the speed and complexity of
the moves you'll be pulling off after
only a few hours is jaw dropping we are
a lightning fast assassin running
constantly where a single bullet can
bring an end to your run this game has a
tough learning curve to help against
being shot we have the ability to slow
down time to take in the whole scenario
before jumping back into warp speed we
have a grappling hook and some ultra fun
cyber abilities to choose from in my
opinion ghost runner shouldn't be missed
depending on who you are the game is
extremely difficult and can be tough so
take a break if you're getting
frustrated but always know each time you
pass a room or zone your spawn will
update so you'll never have to go there
ever again as long as you go in being
prepared for a challenge and constant
dance music to keep you on edge you'll
have fun brutally hard at times but
hugely rewarding too next we have a
playstation multiplayer spin-off from
the brilliant ghost of tsushima this is
legends playing as a samurai hunter
ronin or assassin you'll battle through
japanese mythology you can do this alone
but it's the cooperative element that
makes this title stand out going
back-to-back with a friend in a
last-ditch standoff to claim a capture
point or planning the perfect approach
in an online squad working together to
fend off demonic foes and reviving
fallen comrades mid-battle really adds
to the drama like the single-player game
timing and reacting are much more
important in battle than simply smashing
as many buttons as you can and to make
us aware of this the progression system
leans into it it rewards us with moves
and techniques via a skill tree on
release day there was nine maps to play
through each with a different link to
the mythology of ancient japan and each
map has three variations to play through
bronze silver and the coveted gold oh
and as it's online expect a crazy amount
of cosmetics to stand out from your team
and emote too some of which are just
wrong in all the right ways on the ps4
now and arc survival evolved a survival
action title set in the prehistoric land
when dinosaurs were a regular occurrence
you awake on an island luckily you have
enough clothing to cover your junk but
that's about it it's now your job to
stay alive while getting to know the
island each day you get through is one
day closer to technological advancement
you'll go from throwing a spear at a
dinosaur on day one to sniping t-rex's
with a custom bolt-action rifle one day
playing in either third or first person
the core game is scavenging and building
somewhere safe to live alone this is
tough but with friends the game really
shines and if you choose to do this
online has 64 player servers to occupy
and the thing is trust do you trust the
other 63 players here as at any moment
they can stab you in the back literally
scores average at seven out of ten but
there has been many add-ons both free
and paid over the years which changed
the experience i've always wanted to try
this on playstation so i'm gonna jump in
how about you and then we have another
game sonic is here but it's not the
sonic you're thinking of it's team sonic
racing a mario kart style racer with a
few new ideas the core of every sonic
game is to go fast and here speed is in
abundance sonic racing uses a team
approach and expects you to act like a
unit sticking together the car in front
leaves a slipstream which lets the
others slingshot past before they return
the favor it's like a game of leapfrog
with your teammates whilst racing other
than that it's like mario kart with the
usual projectile items traps and speed
items to grab with online and local
multiplayer there's more life to sonic
team racing than you may expect so
that's the month of march what say you
do me a favor rank them in the comments
i'm adam you're awesome see ya